[Music]
my name is Freddie and I'm gonna be
practicing self-care for a week I've
been hearing a lot about mindfulness
clean eating and clean beauty brands
like bare minerals and how making little
life changes by embracing that power of
good can make a huge difference I'm
going out of town for work which can get
stressful so I thought this would be a
good time to try and face this whole
self-care thing I don't think I really
have a self-care routine
I guess my idea of self-care is watching
TV and then getting my toes done when I
realize they're chips so my plan this
week is to do lots of me time and treat
my body and mind the best I can
I'm also going to be teaming up with
bareMinerals for the week because it's a
beauty line that I already know has
clean ingredients and improve skin over
time and that's gonna be a huge part of
my journey here we go ever since I was a
young child I always hated the grocery
store it's cold it's boring but for the
sake of this I wanted to approach it
with new goals in mind a lot of I don't
like cooking but once I do it and one of
us is gonna have the meal I'm so happy
that I did it and now it's an important
first step and getting into that power
of good mode self-care okay so I just
landed in New York City a couple of
hours ago I'm here in the city for work
but I am going to get ready throw on
some makeup and go hang out with my
girlfriend I use this new less is more
makeup approach for my dinner with the
friend so I use a bare mineral
foundation that I really like I don't
typically use powder foundations but
this week is all about trying new things
New York is an oily City New York is a
hot city so having that powder to sort
of minimize all the shine was great so
I'm back in LA and my next step on the
self-care journey is to try this whole
meditation thing
and who better to show me the power of
good and the meditation Queen herself
Devon then you have your salt lamp you
have this lamp and then you have this
just kind of like a white noise machine
this is one space okay I'm gonna give it
a quick try
[Music]
it was really nice to take a quiet
moment to myself and reflect I've been
on this self-care journey for a few days
now so I'm trying to tap into my own
power of good by being kind of myself
and taking mental breaks I do feel a
little better
my mind feels a little clearer I don't
really have a skin routine right now
because I'm lazy but this week I'm gonna
try to stick to it my skin feels really
good after taking the time to pay really
close attention to it while using new
products while getting enough rest I was
like wait a minute
maybe I should do this skin care thing a
little bit more often this morning I was
struggling to get to the gym it's just
the getting started that's hard and then
afterwards I'm like so happy and so
grateful that I did it and now off to
the office I was a little worried going
into this experiment because while
self-care is really fun and great in
theory I was thinking I'm gonna be
adding more steps into my already very
busy work day and now I'm so happy that
I did it because all these little
changes I made actually felt like I was
taking away steps and at the end of the
day these changes can really build up to
make a huge difference and that's what
self-care and the power of good is all
about right
[Music]